während die abgeordneten jetzt abstimmen
schauen wir schon mal auf dem nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt da wird es etwas
historisch es geht nämlich um
erbansprüche von den hohenzollern seit
mehr als fünf jahren sind der bund die
länder berlin und brandenburg mit den
hund sondern in verhandlungen über
mögliche erbansprüche eben von den hund
sollen einerseits geht es dort um
immobilien zum beispiel um der pakt um
den potsdamer schloss cecilienhof und
andere schloss willen aber es geht auch
um kunstwerke und sammlungs gegenstände
da ist eben die frage ob jetzt zum
beispiel die hohenzollern top team das
wieder zugesprochen wird und bund und
länder wollen natürlich dass solche
kunstwerke auch grundsätzlich der
öffentlichkeit zugänglich sind und die
linken haben sich schon einerseits die
linke in brandenburg als auch die linke
jetzt hier im bundestag und so wie die
ganze partei haben sich schon häufiger
dazu geäußert das werden sie jetzt auch
hier als erstes tun jan korte der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer spricht
zunächst im jahre 2020 mit den
nachwirkungen der monarchie beschäftigen
ja das ist eine gute frage da wir ja
alle wissen und das auch breit gefeiert
haben das erfreulicherweise mit der
revolution von 1918 die monarchie
hinweggefegt wurde wofür wir den
revolutionären revolutionären heute noch
dankbar sein können
meine damen und herren denn die
monarchie ist natürlich war konstitution
das gegenteil von demokratie ist die
gegenteil das gegenteil
gegenüber der herrschaft der bevölkerung
aber es geht um was folgendes ja mit mit
lehren aus der geschichte haben sie es
nun wirklich nicht das wissen hier
deswegen sind sie doch erstmal
grundsätzlich raus aus dieser frage es
geht um etwas ganz handfest ist die
familie die so genannte erden
gemeinschaft der hohenzollern möchte
eine entschädigung haben für
enteignungen die es nach 1945
umfangreich gegeben hat denn damals
schätzte sowohl die sowjetische
militäradministration als auch dann
später die ddr den deutschen adel als
zutiefst verstrickt und mit einer der
hauptursachen für den
nationalsozialismus und hat ihn deswegen
in seinem geltungsbereich vollständig
enteignet und diese entscheidung um es
hier einmal klar auszusprechen war
historisch und moralisch durch und durch
richtig bei allen anderen seal
entscheiden sie es damals gegeben und
das war klasse
nun geht es zum zweiten das wird alles
gleich zusammengefasst um noch etwas
anderes also diese irgendwie besagte
ehren gemeinschaft möchte hinzu eine
rückgabe sehr viele kulturgüter und das
bizarrste in den forderungen was er
selbst an der staatsministerin die auch
da es irgendwann zu bunt wurde war die
forderung des sogenannten hauses
hohenzollern ein unentgeltliches
wohnrecht im schloss cecilienhof im
schloss lindstedt oder der villa
liegnitz das ist natürlich so dermaßen
abgedreht wenn man sich das auch mal
überlegt überhaupt so etwas zu
formulieren und deswegen muss ich ja
leider feststellen dass offenbar die
hohenzollern und mental noch nicht in
der republik angekommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
danke herr achim post von der
spd-fraktion sind sie haben jetzt gerade
explizit die haltung der damaligen ddr
regierung aufgeführt und auch die
ursprünglich erhobene forderung dar und
soll an ein wohnrecht schlosses
cecilienhof zu erlangen
die forderung wurde mittlerweile
freigelassen aber bestimmt wurde
ursprünglich oben meine frage ist ihnen
bekannt dass am dritten mai 1988 erich
honecker einem brief unterzeichnet hat
indem den hohenzollern explizit ein
wohnrecht schloss cecilienhof eingeräumt
werden sollte wenn im gegenzug die särge
der verstorbenen königs friedrich
wilhelm des ersten und friedrich das
zweite wieder zurück nach potsdam
überführt worden wären ja das ist die
frage von florian passt eine der
weiteren grundsätzen fehleinschätzung
von erich honecker
also das ist da sind wir uns da völlig
einer meinung so das macht aber die
heutige forderung der nicht besser dass
es dort viele entscheidungen gegeben hat
nur herr posten das noch die antwort
kollege post sie müssen ja einzeln ich
habe ja gesprochen von den enteignungen
nach 1945 und zwar flächendeckend da
stimmen sie mir doch insbesondere als
sozialdemokrat also stichwort revolution
von 1918 und ausrufung der republik an
der ja ihre partei einen gewissen anteil
hatte wenn man so will
da sind wir doch einer meinung dass das
sehr wichtig gewesen ist und wenn hunde
konnten auch dort völlig falsch
entscheidet kann ich da ja nichts für
aber ich kann verstehen dass es falsch
ist ressourcen sie sagen ja also sorry
so sieht's aus also wenn wir jetzt aber
mal weiter gehen wollen wir uns dem
ganzen juristisch nennt es gibt in dem
gesetz von 1994 wo diese
entscheidungsfragen geregelt sind
folgenden passus dass nämlich
entschädigungszahlung dann
ausgeschlossen sind liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen werden in diesem fall die
familie hohenzollern dem
nationalsozialismus wörtliches zitat
erheblichen vorschub geleistet hat dazu
gibt es jetzt ja alle möglichen
gutachten die dank des satirikers
böhmermann ja auch allgemein jetzt allen
zur verfügung gestellt wurden da kann
man auch einfach mal danke sagen um das
nachzulesen
und deswegen stellt sich auch die
business und polit ist die frage haben
die hohenzollern und dort besonders
grund prinz will den nationalsozialismus
forschend geleistet und ich möchte
ulrich herbert ein glaube ich um
unumstrittenen exzellenten historiker
zitieren der auf dieser frage folgendes
geantwortet hat ja gewiss nicht weniger
aber wohl auch nicht mehr als all die
anderen hochrangigen vertreter der
vaterländischen verbände der deutsch
nationalen parteien der klubs und ringe
der rechtsradikalen intellektuellen der
große agraria und der große industrie
die die republik zerstören und das neue
reich der rechten aufbauen wollten
ohne parlament ohne gewerkschaften und
ohne juden allerdings unter der
voraussetzung dass sie selbst dabei
irgendeine
wichtige rolle spielen durften aber wenn
selbst die es nicht waren die vorschub
leisteten dann war es eben keine wie
gehabt zitat ende
das ist der kern der
geschichtspolitischen auseinandersetzung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die wir
führen und das macht noch mal den kern
deutlich warum übrigens auch die
weimarer republik entgegen dem ganzen
hunger erzählt wurde zerstört worden ist
nämlich im bündnis von der großindustrie
von rechtsradikalen und eben den
deutschnationalen konservativen parteien
das hat die weimarer republik zerstört
und es hier auch mal klar auszusprechen
bei all dem unsinn der sonst erzählt
wurde
ja das ist die traditionslinien der sie
stehen ja das ist ihre tradition street
zum vierten zum 4
es geht natürlich hier auch ganz
schlicht um geld es geht hier nicht um
traditionen was ich was dort alles
erzählt wird von irgendwelchen
adelshäusern und es geht schlicht und
kohle und das kann ich auch belegen
gucken wir mal auf die versteigerung im
jahre 2017 der hohenzollern im
auktionshaus sotheby's in florida dort
rücken darf ich noch mal fragen erlauben
sie nochmal eine zwischenfrage oder
bemerkungen vor dem überlegen kampe
inhaltlich dort wurde im jahr 2017 base
bietet folgendes verscherbeln nämlich
ein vergoldetes trinkgefäß von friedrich
dem ersten im wert von 2,6 millionen
euro und fünf gemälde unter anderem mit
ansichten vom berliner stadtschloss
inklusive einrichtungsgegenstände also
die stadt fluss wo mehr oder minder
aufgeklärte bürgerliche kreise sehr viel
geld für gesammelt haben um es wieder
aufzubauen wahnsinniger weise aber das
ist eine andere eine andere diskussion
also das wurde dort verscherbelt und die
staatsministerin professor grütters hat
natürlich recht
durch und durch wenn sie sagt dass
national wertvolle kunstwerke zitat
natürlich in das museum gehören und der
allgemeinheit zugänglich gemacht werden
und nicht auf den internationalen kunst
könnten verletzt werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
fünftens jenseits der ganzen frage der
verstrickung in den nationalsozialismus
da gibt es ja noch einiges andere was
man dort mal aufarbeiten konnte das will
ich schon einmal sagen und ganz
grundsätzlich in der geschichte des
adels und der monarchie beruhte
natürlich der wesentliche teil dieses
unermesslichen reichtums der adelshäuser
daraus dass sie die bevölkerung oder
klassisch gesagt das volk ausgeplündert
haben und nicht durch eigene hände
arbeit und dass wir auch mal klar zu
sagen denn wer hat denn die schlösser
und burgen gebaut das war nicht die
monarchen die hand angelegt haben mit
der maurerkelle das waren die
arbeiterinnen und arbeiter daran sollte
man vielleicht mal ganz grundsätzlich
erinnern
und im übrigen wenn wir über die familie
hohenzollern und die geschichte reden
will ich auch noch einmal an die
verbrechen der kolonialzeit erinnern das
wäre etwas was sie mal aufarbeiten
sollten da wurde noch nie über
entschädigungen gesprochen
also ich kann namens der fraktion der
linken nur sagen es kann keine
geheimverhandlungen mehr geben keiner
außergerichtlichen absprachen hier
müssen jetzt die gerichte entscheiden
und die forderungen der ehemaligen
adelshäuser sind für die zukunft
gesetzgeberisch auszuschließen denn das
ist der kernbestandteil der demokratie
nämlich die herrschaft der vielen die
herrschaft der bevölkerung und nicht von
irgendwelchen selbsternannten adeligen
mit komischen namen vielen dank für die
auf
jan korte war dass der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der linksfraktion nun
gibt es aber eine kurzintervention von
armin paul haben will von der
fdp-fraktion präsidentin der kollegen
konnten sie darauf aufmerksam machen
dass es die weimarer republik und zwar
demokratisch gewählte parteien und die
bereits gebiete regierungen die ihre
familie hohenzollern damals ihren besitz
aus rechtsstaatlichen gründen gelassen
haben und zwar war das ganz einfach
rechtlicher besitz der familie war und
man hat auch damals das nicht angerührt
da war man demokratischer und
rechtsstaatlicher als sie es je sein
werden
zweitens verwehre mich dagegen dass
gegen eine gruppe diffamieren in unserem
lande und der eine mitschuld am zweiten
dritten reich unterstellen sie haben es
ja gerade selber ausgeführt von
historikern bewegt wie jeder andere auch
war auch jede gesellschaftliche gruppe
mal so oder mal so an der entwicklung
des dritten reiches beteiligt ich ältere
allerdings auch an das was wir haben
gegen zwanzigster juli warten dann sei
der adelige familie von stauffenberg war
die gegen das dritte reich leib und
leben eingesetzt hat und das projekt der
zu respektieren
im übrigen kurzintervention übrigen
würde ich mich freuen wenn sie schon
über das vermögen und die besitz der
familie hohenzollern debattieren wollen
dann überlegen sie sich ob sie im
gleichen gegenzug endlich anbieten wo
die verschwundenen sed milliarden
geblieben sind
ich darf wieder zurückgeben danke schön
sehen sie bitte
stimmen und herr korte herr kollege über
dubiose geldflüsse sollten ausgerechnet
sie von der afg hier besser kein
verständnis
dann würden sie erst mal die welt wieder
hoffen wagen von der schweiz gesteuert
die fünfte kolonne oder so was da an
geldtresor fließen also das sollen sie
erst mal klären und es gibt eine
bundestagsdrucksache wo die
vermögensfragen der sed und der
ehemaligen massenorganisationen der ddr
druckreif denken liegt in der regel
bricht der damaligen kommission die es
gegeben hat also deswegen das ging schon
mal voll daneben
das zweite wurst umgeht das ist ja ein
widerspruch die dankenswerterweise dem
plenum offenbar die damaligen
entschädigungszahlungen und die
behandlung der ehemaligen monarchen und
ihre angehörigen wurde er 1926 geregelt
und dort kann man ja festhalten ich
hoffe dass sie das kennen das dort ja
mit den ehemaligen arien mit den
adelshäuser also sehr sehr nett und
freundlich umgegangen worden ist ja
deswegen haben wir heute überhaupt noch
diesen debatten also deswegen geht auch
das zum zweiten ins leere und eigentlich
ihnen schon noch mal sagen hoffe dass
sie das nicht wirklich so gemeint haben
ich glaube nicht dass
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
mitglieder der bekennenden kirche
kommunistinnen und kommunisten
gewerkschafterinnen und gewerkschafter
haben mit sicherheit keinen anteil an
dem sieg hitlers und dem ns terror
regime um das mal ganz deutlich zu sagen
er geradezu absurd
aber das ganze ist ja auch geschäft
vertreten
dann kommen wir zur zweiten ringerin in
der debatte elisabeth motschmann für die
cdu/csu-fraktion elisabeth motschmann
ist die kultur und medienpolitische
sprecherin ihrer fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kollegen und kolleginnen herr korte ich
darf sie an eines vielleicht zu nicht
erinnern
alle menschen sind vor dem gesetz gleich
dieser dieser aus artikel 3 unseres
grundgesetzes gilt auch für die familie
hohenzollern punkt der friedrich prinz
von preußen ist ein bundesbürger wie
jeder andere auch er trägt keinen
adelstitel
sondern einen namenszusatz die monarchie
gibt es seit dem 9 november 1918 nicht
mehr das haben sie hoffentlich auch
schon gemerkt seitdem hat der adel
keinerlei privilegien mehr und das ist
gut so meine damen und herren
aber eines gilt für diese familie wie
für alle anderen auch
sie können ihre rechte wahrnehmen
verhandeln und einklagen und ich hoffe
nicht dass sie ihn das absprechen wollen
das ist das allerletzte
der bund und die länder berlin und
brandenburg verhandeln seit 19 2014 mit
dem hund soll
ziel war und ist es eine einvernehmlich
und vor allem eine außergerichtliche
lösung zu finden die für beide seiten
akzeptabel ist
genau so ist es geschehen in anderen
bundesländern mit den adelshäusern der
wettiner und der wittelsbacher die haben
das erfolgreich vorgemacht die rückgabe
ansprüche sind sache der
verhandlungspartner der deutsche
bundestag entscheidet darüber nicht und
das ist gut so
wo kommen wir denn hin wenn gesetzlich
verbriefte rechte zum spielball
parteipolitischer motivierter debatten
werden
diese haltung ist unverantwortlich als
größter leihgeber der stiftung
preußische schlösser und gärten stellt
die familie und sollen bereits heute
viele kulturgüter der öffentlichkeit zur
verfügung das werden sie ja wohl wissen
die gespräche mit den hund sondern
wollen wir fortsetzen und nach
möglichkeit eine langwierige und
aufwendige gerichtliche
auseinandersetzung vermeiden
sie plädieren in ihrem antrag für die
enteignung der hohenzollern selbst wenn
ihnen die gerichte ansprüche zu sprechen
mit enteignung sind sie die linken ja
immer schnell bei der hand
nur damit verlassen sie den boden
unserer verfassung
auch in diesem fall und das lehnen wir
ab
ein solches verständnis von unserem
rechtsstaat ist unverantwortlich
deutsche gerichte werden entscheiden am
ende wenn es keine einvernehmliche
regelung gibt und das sollten sie bitte
auch akzeptieren
wir wollen an einer einvernehmlichen
lösung weiter arbeiten die hohenzollern
werden werden unsere museen übrigens das
ist ein ganz übles vorurteil ganz sicher
nicht ausräumen seien sie mal gewiss wir
wünschen uns dass diese verhandlungen
zügig vorangetrieben werden dafür müssen
sich beide seiten aufeinander zubewegen
übrigens und jetzt komme ich nochmal auf
den von herrn post schon von kollegen
post schon angesprochene tatsache zurück
dass 1926 zugestandene und heute
umstrittene wohnrecht in schloss
cecilienhof wurde schon in den achtziger
jahren von der ddr-regierung von
honecker persönlich in erwägung gezogen
im gegenzug sollte der sagt friedrich
des großen nach post potsdam
zurückkehren
louis ferdinand von preußen war bereit
den saab zu überführen von der hofburg
wurden sollen
und das hat er auch da aber er hat die
bedingung gestellt in einem
wiedervereinigten deutschland das war
seine bedingung und deshalb ist der sarg
auch 1991 nach sanssouci gekommen sie
weisen in ihrem antrag jegliche
ansprüche der hohenzollern zurück und
sie wissen genau dass voraussetzung
dafür dass sie keine ansprüche haben
die frage ist ob sie vorschub geleistet
haben dem naziregime ja oder nein
so sieht es das
ausgleichsleistungsgesetz von 1994 vor
ob der kronprinz den nazis erheblich
vorschub geleistet hat ist unter
historikern und das haben sie vergessen
zu sagen hoch umstritten
sie haben es gibt ein cut der gutachten
und ich zitiere jetzt bitte mal
christopher clark aus cambridge den
viele kennen ich zitiere kronprinz
willen hat dem nationalsozialistischen
system keinen erheblichen vorschub
geleistet seine handlungen waren nicht
dazu geeignet die bedingung für die
errichtung die entwicklung oder die
ausbreitung des nationalsozialistischen
systems zu verbessern
zitat ende eines der der gutachten die
in frage stehen die links vorn maßt sich
an alles besser zu wissen als historiker
von höchstem renommee die in rede stehen
in ansprüche der hohenzollern sind
allesamt bürgerlich rechtliche ansprüche
die auf einem gesetz über die vermögens
auseinandersetzungen zwischen dem staat
und dem haus hohenzollern aus dem jahr
1926 sowie auf dem
ausgleichsleistungsgesetz von 94 gründen
der antrag der linken basiert auf einer
zum teil polemisch geführten debatte ob
jan böhmermann der spiegel oder die
partielle diskutieren diskreditieren den
adel und sie haben es auch getan und das
ist üblich kübel gucken sie sich doch
mal an wie viele adlige in diesem
parlament sitzen die gute demokraten
sind
ich lese
ich lese ein ich lese ein zitat aus dem
spiegel
der adel ist im allgemeinen die hallen
sondern ganz speziell eine plage für
land und leute dieses land schuldet den
hund soll an keine einzige kaffeetasse
von kunstschätzen oder immobilien
ich komme zum ende genau in diesen
populistischen geist haben sie den
vorliegenden antrag formuliert wie
legitimieren die enteignung der ddr
übrigens ein undemokratischer
unrechtsstaat enteignung schon garnicht
enteignungen in einem unrechtsstaat
entsprechen nicht unseren grundrechten
frau motto das ist gut so liebe
präsidentin ich bin am ende und bedanke
mich sehr herzlich für die
aufmerksamkeit
elisabeth motschmann die zweite rednerin
in dieser doch jetzt schon recht
emotionalen debatte nächster redner ist
alexander gauland der
fraktionsvorsitzende der fw fraktion
auch präsidentin meine damen und herren
zuerst einmal das deutsche volk hat
seine die präsidierten fürsten nach der
katastrophe von 1918 gut behandelt
friedrich ebert schickte dem pflicht
vergessenen kaiser 60 güterwagen mit
seiner persönlichen habe ins
holländische exil nach im haus doorn
kann man sie heute noch besichtigen und
auch bei der fürsten abfindung ist
darüber gesprochen worden 19 26 blieben
die herrscher häuser im besitz von
schlossen gütern beton und eco erste
katastrophe des zweiten weltkrieges die
maßnahmen der sowjetischen
besatzungsmacht und die verluste der
deutschen ostgebiete an die sowjetunion
und polen machten aus die nach 1918
immer noch sehr wohlhabenden
hohenzollern eine fast normale
bürgerliche familie und für diese gilt
vom entspannt hat es gesagt nach dem
einigungsvertrag wie für alle anderen
geschädigten auch rückgabe der
beweglichen habe und entschädigung für
endgültig verlorene immobilienbesitz wir
leben gott sei dank in einem rechtsstaat
die gespräche zwischen dem haus
hohenzollern der bundesregierung den
ländern berlin und brandenburg laufen
noch übrigens schon seit 2014 beginnen
sich plötzlich revolutionäre töne in die
verhandlungen einzuschleichen
denn entschädigung und rückgabe
entfallen
der geschädigte dem nationalsozialismus
in erheblicher weise vorschub geleistet
hat und genau diesen eigentlich
historischen streit der ohne einigung am
ende wohl vor gericht ausgetragen werden
berichte die linke vorab politisch
entscheiden
für sie sind die hohenzollern schuldig
und verdienen keinen cent entschädigung
nun besteht kein zweifel dass der letzte
kaiser in turm sein ältester sohn der
frühere kronprinz und einige seiner
brüder besonders prinz august wilhelm
weder klug noch leidenschaftliche
demokraten warnung des mindest zu sein
ja und ich weiß es gibt die bilder auf
denen der kronprinz mit hitler passiert
zum beispiel am tage von potsdam
ja sie hofften auf eine italienische
lösung - einige faschismus und monarchie
eine lösung allerdings fehler nie in
frage kam
und da sind wir bei den intellektuellen
fähigkeiten der damaligen unzen
sie waren doch sehr bescheiden und die
des kronprinzen
die hat schon sein vater nicht geräumt
sie waren sehr bescheiden so dass viel
für das urteil von christopher clark
spricht sie konnten mangels
intellektueller und politischer masse
dem nationalsozialismus nicht in
erheblicher weise vorschub leisten
ja ich weiß meine damen und herren
kann das alles auch kritisch sehen ring
sich nicht auf und andere historiker
sehen das kritisch auch dass aber
ausgerechnet die linke sich hier zum
richter aufschwingen will ist an
heuchelei nicht zu überbieten hat worte
denn es waren doch ihre geistigen väter
die kommunisten die mit dem kampf gegen
den sozial faschismus also die
sozialdemokratie einer abwehr volk gegen
die nazis verhinderten
und schlimmer noch beim bvg streik 1932
haben sie gemeinsame sache mit den
nationalsozialisten gemacht walter
ulbricht in streikkomitee zogen sowohl
walter ulbricht joseph goebbels der
gauleiter von berlin gemeinsam die fäden
das ist die vergangenheit ihrer partei
wer im glashaus sitzt meine damen und
herren
und ich sage liebe kollegen von der
linken sollte nicht mit steinen auf die
hohenzollern werden
deshalb sollten diese verhandlungen form
als völlig richtig gesagt mit dem ziel
einer einigung fair zu ende geführt
werden schließt es gibt es nicht nur die
letzten kaiser und seinen missratenen
sohn sondern eine familie die nicht weit
von hier aus der streusandbüchse des
alten reiches ein ästhetisch
vollkommenes arkadien geschaffen hat an
dem sich auch heute millionen besucher
des in und auslands jedes jahr freuen
ja ich kenne die einwände des lesenden
arbeiters herr korte hat es auch wieder
versucht herbert albrecht nicht zitiert
aber genau in die richtung geht es nur
am ende
meine lieben kollegen von der linken war
es friedrich
das hast du sie geschaffen hat und nicht
der baum mit der kelle wenn er hat es
entworfen
seien wir also gnädig mit den
hohenzollern
sie haben nur die fehler gemacht die
leider viele unserer großväter und
großmütter millionenfach auch gemacht
haben
insofern waren sie was schon walther
rathenau kurz nach der niederlage von
1918 über wilhelm den zweiten
festgestellt hat ein fast perfektes
symbol für die verirrungen eines volkes
bei denen wir sie jetzt nicht alleine
lassen sollten
ich bedanke mich alexander gauland war
dass der fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp
fraktion
auf ihn folgt jetzt haye gelingt er ist
sprecher für demokratie der spd-fraktion
und spricht hier zum antrag der
linksfraktion keine entschädigung an
nachkommen der monarchie da geht es um
die erb gemeinschaft der hund zu lernen
euro präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ein paar meter von hier auf dem
balkon hat 1918 der sozialdemokrat
philipp scheidemann die deutsche
republik ausgerufen
auf der grundlage kann ich feststellen
dass die spd-bundestagsfraktion gewiss
nicht die entschuldigung und
entschädigung exkulpieren oder auch
rehabilitierung der hund sondern als
ihre politische aufgabe erachtet und ich
finde das auch gut so
zum zweiten hat hier an dieser stelle
auch otto wels damals die würde aller
demokratinnen und demokraten der
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
hat sich auch der verbauten
kommunistinnen und kommunisten und alle
anderer die widerständig waren
verteidigt deshalb lege ich und ich lege
im namen unserer aller großen wert
darauf dies als form des widerstandes
gegen das ns system zu kennzeichnen und
einen deutlichen unterschied zu machen
zum verhalten des damaligen damaligen
monate zwischen geschlecht des scheins
notwendig zu sein in den debatten die
wir gegenwärtig erleben das deutlich zu
machen weil ich inzwischen dem medialen
diskurs entnehme das formulierung zu
finden sind wie die rolle war umstritten
und damit kann ich mich ehrlich gesagt
nicht abfinden und ich sage das sine ira
et studio und nicht mit zorn so als
nüchterne analyse es geht nicht darum
irgendwie revanchistisch jetzt die
hohenzollern abzustrafen und mir geht es
auch überhaupt nicht darum abzurechnen
mit preußen oder mit dem radl piquet
mich darauf ich bin ein großer anhänger
der preußischen reformer ich habe mit
begeisterung wilhelm von humboldt
gelesen aber darum geht es nicht es geht
hier um verschiedene fragen die in
diesem ganzen diskurs leicht
durcheinander gebracht werden die uns
aber nicht dazu bringen sollten auch die
ethische dimension des ganzen zu
vergessen
und bevor ich zu den details punkten
komme wage ich doch darauf hinzuweisen
dass es ganz ganz viele letztlich
millionen von deutschen gab die in
dieses land aus dem osten flüchteten die
nicht große entschädigung erfahren haben
den es deutlich schlechter ergangen ist
als den hohenzollern und ich erinnere
auch daran dass wir uns alle relativ
schwer damit tun bestimmte opfergruppen
ich nenne hier zum beispiel die
sogenannten berufsverbrecher sozialen
oder die opfer der atom ära sie
überhaupt als verfolgte des ns-regimes
anzuerkennen dieser kontext steht nicht
nur minimalen zusammenhang mit dieser
debatte aber wir können noch nicht
ausblenden dass wie
erheblich ist noch zu tun haben um
tatsächliche opfer des ns regimes zu
würdigen und uns nicht allein zu
beschäftigen ob hinreichend das erbe der
hohenzollern gewürdigt wird ich glaube
das muss man auch mal deutlich
formulieren jetzt kommen wir zu den
einzelnen ebenen einerseits ist da die
rechtlich ebenen es wurde schon erwähnt
es geht lässt sich in form der ausgleich
verhandlung jetzt auch keine
geheimverhandlungen waren also geheim
sind sie wahrlich nicht in diesen
verhandlungen die auf basis der
sogenannten fürsten der 20er jahre
stattgefunden haben um die
vermögensauseinandersetzung den vertrag
von 25 26 und es geht um das
ausgleichsleistungsgesetz das ist eine
rechtliche frage und wir haben parallel
dazu interagieren
aber man muss es sagen die situation zb
in brandenburg ein gerichtsverfahren
verwaltungsgerichtsverfahren das dann
ruhig gestellt wurde
aufgrund der ausgleichs verhandlung und
da geht es um immobilien um die rückgabe
von immobilien bzw
da das dann nicht möglich waren
abgelehnt wurde um
entschädigungszahlungen dir und soll an
haben gegen die entscheidung des landes
brandenburg geklagt das ist die
dimension über die wir sprechen und in
diesem zusammenhang in dem zusammenhang
von brandenburg kam es auch zu denen
schon genannten vier gutachten von
history die rechtliche frage die sich
darstellt ist keine moralische herzlich
es geht da nicht um die entscheidung von
schuld und es ist auch nicht die frage
eines großen historischen wert und teils
das wird an anderer stelle entschieden
werden sondern es ist in der
formulierung die frage ich zitiere das
ausgleichsleistungsgesetz ob erheblich
vorschub geleistet wurde und das ist
auch klar definiert von gerichten und es
wurde noch mal bestätigt im verfahren in
bezug auf fockenberg 2005 vom
bundesverwaltungsgericht
es geht da um stetige handlung
die die bedingung der errichtung und
entwicklung des ns systems verbessert
haben und erheblich bedeutet dass das
nicht ganz unbedeutende beiträge waren
ich bin jetzt nicht juristen das steht
nicht an mir das zu entscheiden aber ich
denke es spricht sehr viel dafür dass
diese rechtlichen kriterien in dem
fahrrad erfüllt worden
deshalb vertraue ich auch da auf die
womöglich letztlich kommenden
juristischen entscheidungen
es gibt aber auch noch eine andere
dimension ich glaube die muss man an
diesem tag erwähnen und sie kam bisher
noch nicht zum zug
es gibt auch so was wie eine
geschichtspolitische dimension des
ganzen
und ich stelle fest dass hoch bedeuten
historikerinnen und historiker dieses
landes momentan sich in einer etwas
schwierigen situation befinden
stefan marcinowski war konfrontiert mit
einer strafanzeige durch das geschlecht
der hohenzollern r verfahren wurde
eingestellt
in diesem augenblick gibt es
unterlassungsbegehren einstweilige
verfügung ich nenne als beispiel martin
sabel tochter winfried süß katharina
urban höchst anerkannte historikern als
dritter dieses landes und nicht zu
unrecht und ich bringe mich unmöglich
jetzt selbst in die gefahr verklagt zu
werden aber das stört mich nicht
muss darauf hingewiesen werden dass im
tagesspiegel martin sabrow von einer
unkultur der einschüchterung gesprochen
hat und von einer gefährdung der
freiheit der wissenschaft sehr geehrte
damen und herren ich denke als parlament
können wir diesen umstand nicht
ignorieren
daher
steht es mir nicht an groß ratschläge zu
erteilen
ich kann nur sagen was ich täte wäre ich
ein mitglied des geschlechtes simon
zoller
ich würde die chance ergreifen mich als
moderne ehemalige monarchenfamilie zu
präsentieren mit entsprechender
bescheinigt ich würde deutlich machen
dass im jahr an allen möglichen gelegen
ist und dass ich so souverän die
geschichte meines hauses aufzuklären
womöglich expertenkommission oder
ähnliches einzuberufen das soll man
entscheiden und wie mehr daran gelegen
die demokratie dieses landes zu stärken
und deutlich zu machen dass ich zu
dieser stehe und dass das die
entscheidende frage ist und das ist ein
unterschied ist ob man opfer war oder
täter und das gewiss kronprinz wilhelm
kein gras hüter der demokratie in diesem
lande war und das sage ich zum schluss
und das sage ich als sozialdemokrat in
bezug auf otto wels und philipp
scheidemann
wir haben nichts als sozialdemokraten
erlebt dass die hohenzollern uns damals
unterstützt hätten nein im gegenteil es
waren die eliten und dazu gehörte auch
dieses geschlecht damals damit die
heutigen person nichts zu tun aber es
war damals der geschichte umstand die
uns geschwächt haben im kampf gegen die
entstehung des nationalsozialismus das
ist ein unterschied der unterschied
macht und auf der grundlage verhalten
uns auch vielen dank vielen dank
nächster redner hartmut erwin für die
fraktion der fdp hatten und eving ist
der kulturpolitische sprecher seiner
fraktion
[Applaus]
so verknüpfen sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen manche
anträge die wir hier in diesem haus
diskutieren verwundern mich schon sehr
wer hier vorgelegter antrag der linken
besteht eigentlich nur aus
simplifizierten klassenkampf und
verfassungsrechtlich bedenklichen
kollektivierung fahnder wähnen sich
einfach so sagen die tatsache dass sie
behaupten jegliche
entschädigungsansprüche aus
entscheidungen der sowjetischen
militäradministration seien
grundsätzlich auszuschließen offenbart
einmal mehr ihre ideologische nähe zum
sozialistischen gedankengut der
sowjetunion noch viel grotesker ist aber
die forderung der forderungskatalog aus
ihrem antrag
darin fordern sie zunächst den abbruch
der verhandlungen mit der familie
preußen und die wiederaufnahme des
gerichtlichen prozesses das ist wenn ich
meine meinung aber durchaus noch
vertretbar aber dann entlarven sie sich
denn anstatt eines eines von ihnen
geforderten urteils zu akzeptieren
fordern sie für den fall dass ihnen das
urteil nicht passt
eine erneute umfängliche entschied
enteignung der familie brüssel
ja das steht in ihrem antrag da frage
ich mich schon ob sie noch auf dem boden
der verfassung stehen oder sich nicht
insgeheim die wiedererrichtung eines
unrechtsstaates wünschen
die bundesrepublik deutschland ist
jedoch zum glück immer noch ein
rechtsstaat und daher sind vor dem
gesetz alle bürger gleich egal ob meier
müller wagenknecht oder preußen heißen
wer in der bundesrepublik deutschland
einen rechtmäßigen anspruch besitzt kann
diesen unabhängig vom alter geschlecht
sexualität herkunft oder namen geltend
machen der rechtsstaat schützt nicht nur
das gesellschaftliche miteinander
sondern auch den einzelnen bürger vor
potenziellen übergriffen des staates ein
grundpfeiler des schutzmechanismus ist
das zugestehen eines fairen verfahrens
essentieller teil eines solchen
rechtsstaatlichen verfahrens sind auch
verhandlungen zwischen konfliktparteien
nur so ist das oftmals möglich eine für
beide seiten akzeptable lösung
herbeizuführen
dies geht naturgemäß insbesondere für
komplexe sachverhalte wie wir es in
diesem fall haben die ja schon
feststellen
ich möchte es von einigen auch hier
vorgetragen trotzdem auch die den fall
etwas darstellen für entschädigungen bei
enthaltungen durch die sowjetische
militäradministration zwischen 45 und 49
verabschiedet der bundestag 1994 das
ausgleichs weißes gesetz dieser einen
symbolischen finanziellen ausgleich
findet verlust von immobilien vor sowie
die rückgabe von mobilien diese
ansprüche verfallen jedoch wenn der
anspruchsteller oder derjenige von dem
der anspruchsteller seinen anspruch
ableiten dem nationalsozialistischen
regime erheblichen vorschub geleistet
hat im fall preußen streiten sich
darüber seit jahren namhafte historiker
das wird ihnen streit das ist nicht so
dass sie jetzt dass wir irgendwie jetzt
sehen da ist jetzt eindeutig eine
mahnung dass ein streit zwischen
historiker und juristen wie ein gericht
dieses ausschlusskriterium bewerten
auch nach vorlage weiterer gutachten
finde ich ist pure hellseherei und
vollkommen ungewiss
im falle von immobilien und mobile
hingegen die während die die während der
sowjetischen besatzungszeit nicht
zweifelsfrei enteignet wurden oder und
der sektion gewalt gestellt worden sind
oder erst nach gründung der ddr
enteignet worden sind dafür gilt nicht
das auf rechts gesetzt sondern dafür
gilt das gesetz zur regelung offener
vermögensfragen besser bekannt als
vermögensgesetz und in diesem
vermögensgesetz steht nichts drin dass
die rückgabe ausgeschlossen ist wenn dem
nationalsozialismus erheblich vorschub
geleistet worden ist denn wenn die
ansprüche nach vermögensgesetz also
durchgehend dann muss ich zurückgeben
nach gesetz im fall der familie preußens
nach meiner kenntnis noch nicht
ansatzweise geklärt welche
kunstgegenstände wann genau enteignet
worden sind und ob sie somit unter dem
ausgleichsleistungsgesetz fallen oder an
das vermögensgesetz nachweispflicht
hierfür sind nach meiner kenntnis nach
der staat sollten kulturgüter unter das
vermögensgesetz fallen müssten diese
ohne zweifel vollumfänglich zurück
gegeben werden und der staat hätte
grundsätzlich keinerlei einfluss mehr
auf den öffentlichen zugriff der fall
ist also höchst komplex und sollte die
gerichte über jahre oder jahrzehnte
beschäftigen und könnte womöglich
verheerende auswirkungen für die
öffentlichen museen haben
deswegen finde ich es richtig und auch
gut dass die bundesregierung gemeinsam
mit den ländern berlin und brandenburg
in verhandlungen mit der familie preußen
eingetreten ist und damit dem beispiel
alle anderen ostdeutschen
landesregierungen folgt sachsen
thüringen sachsen anhalt und mecklenburg
vorpommern haben alle ins allesamt
gütliche einigungen durch verhandlungen
mit dem jeweiligen mit den jeweiligen
adelsfamilien erzielt nur so war es
möglich dass wir heute alle weiterhin
die klassik stiftung weimar und ihren
unschätzbaren kulturellen wert
öffentlich genießen können
auch die sammlung im grünen gewölbe in
dresden wäre ohne eine gütliche einigung
nicht denkbar
von welch unschätzbaren emotionalen wert
diese sammlung in dresden hat wissen wir
ja seit dem tragischen hombruch vor
kurzem viele öffentliche museen kann ein
gerichtsverfahren zu massiven und
unterband verlusten führen die nie mehr
rückgängig zu machen wären in
verhandlungen allerdings kann man
sicherstellen dass ein gros möglicher
teil der kulturgüter durch
nutzungsverträge weiterhin der
öffentlichkeit zugänglich bleibt und
nicht meistbietend bei christie's und
sotheby's im ausland verkauft werden
solche verhandlungen erlauben es die
familie von preußen im gegensatz zur
rückübertragung vertraglich dazu
verpflichten die große mehrheit der
kunstgegenstände sowohl aus west- als
auch im osten über dauerleihgaben und in
würde alle vereinbarungen für die
öffentlichkeit zugelegt zu halten
dies wäre nicht nur für die kulturelle
vielfalt der bundesrepublik von der
nummer bedeutung sondern vielmehr auch
für die kulturelle bildung der
nachfolgenden generationen denn wenn wir
dauerhaft den öffentlichen zugang zu
diesen kulturgütern verlieren würden
wäre das ein kaum zu bemessen der
verlust für unsere gesellschaft
gleichwohl gleichwohl fordern wir beide
seiten auf die seit 1906 2014
bestehenden verhandlungen nunmehr zügig
abzuschließen vielen dank vielen dank
nächster redner für bündnis 90/die
grünen er hat grund er hat gründe lässt
der kulturpolitische sprecher von
bündnis 90 die grünen also von der
fraktion liebe sehr geehrte anwesende es
hat lange gedauert bis firmen
sportvereine sportclubs ministerium und
behörden begonnen haben sich mit ihrer
nationalsozialistischen vergangenheit
auseinanderzusetzen
in den allermeisten fällen musste diese
auseinandersetzung lange und hart von
der zivilgesellschaft erkämpft werden
abgeschlossen ist sie bis heute nicht
aber diese auseinandersetzung ist
wichtig vor allem dann wenn das wort von
adorno dass auschwitz nicht sich
wiederholt in deutschland als
staatsräson gelten soll
was für firmen und die aufarbeitung
ihrer nationalsozialistischen
vergangenheit gilt muss umso mehr gelten
für das haus hohenzollern
schließlich stellten die hohenzollern
kurfürsten preußischen könige deutsche
kaiser und trugen über 500 jahre
politische verantwortung in deutschland
so steht es jedenfalls auch der
hohenzollern homepage auch wenn die
konfrontation mit schuld in der eigenen
familie schwer fällt
transparenz und bereitschaft zu
ergebnisoffenen auseinandersetzung sind
entscheidend für die aufarbeitung dieses
teils der deutschen geschichte und
transparenz und offenheit genau das
vermisse ich in der auseinandersetzung
mit den fragen die für die derzeit
laufenden entschädigungs verhandlungen
die entscheidenden sind sicherlich ist
es legitim mit juristischen mitteln
gegen falsche tatsachenbehauptungen
vorzugehen
aber wenn man sich anschaut wie
historikerinnen und historiker
journalisten und journalistinnen und
andere die sich im umfeld der jetzigen
diskussion äußern
reihenweise mit unterlassungsklagen
unter druck gesetzt werden frage ich sie
ist dieses abmahn und klageverfahren im
sinn des erkenntnisgewinns zielführend
führt das zu mehr transparenz oder wirkt
dieses vorgehen nicht vielmehr wie ein
versuch die freiheit von wissenschaft
und presse einzuschränken
die frage ob die hohenzollern dem
nationalsozialismus muss in erheblichem
maße vorschub geleistet haben steht im
zentrum des antrags von bündnis 90/die
grünen und diese frage steht im zentrum
der öffentlichen anhörung am 29 januar
im ausschuss für kultur und medien wo
viele der vorhin genannten
historikerinnen und historiker zu wort
kommen werden
diese frage steht im zentrum unseres
antrags weil die derzeit laufenden
verhandlungen der kulturstaatsministerin
mit den hohenzollern auf der grundlage
des ausgleichsleistungsgesetz von 94
erfolgen
das gesetz schafft eine besondere
rechtslage angesichts neuer deutschen
geschichte aus nachvollziehbaren gründen
wie es professor christopher clark aus
cambridge in einem spiegel interview im
oktober 2009 10 formuliert in dem er
gleichzeitig seine früheren äußerungen
die sie kollegin motschmann heute hier
auch der herr gauland hier zitieren
relativiert dann auch möchte ich erst
mal hinweisen dass die veraltete zitate
gebracht haben
denn der gesetzgeber hat
eigentumsrechtlichen fragen ein
historisches und politische moralisches
urteil vor ausgestellt wenn die
hohenzollern auch entschädigung nicht
verzichten wollen müssen sie historisch
argumentieren es geht im vorliegenden
fall nicht um schlichte privatrechtliche
eigentumsfragen denn die letztlich von
den gerichten zu klärende frage verlernt
zunächst die beantwortung einer
grundsatzfrage der deutschen geschichte
die frage nach der historischen
verantwortung der hohenzollern für die
machtübernahme der nationalsozialisten
darüber kann nicht im staatsministerium
entschieden werden
das ist eine res publica eine
öffentliche angelegenheit die öffentlich
debattiert werden muss historikerinnen
journalistinnen politikerinnen müssten
hier einbezogen werden
daher war unser erstes ziel
öffentlichkeit herzustellen
und ich danke speziell dem
fernsehmoderator böhmermann der es
geschafft hat diese öffentlichkeit
vehement auszuweiten
in unserem antrag fordern die grünen den
deutschen bundestag auf analog zu
armenien entscheidung sich politisch
historisch zu dieser frage zu äußern
wir fordern den bundestag dazu auf die
auffassung zu teilen dass die
hohenzollern dem nationalsozialismus
erheblich vorschub geleistet haben und
darf der grundlage dieses beschlusses zu
agieren dem bundestag vor über
tagesabschluss einzubeziehen und
vollumfänglich zu informieren aus diesem
grund haben wir die anhörung am 29
januar im ausschuss für kultur und
medien gefordert es ist dabei
entscheidend den anhörungs gegenstand
nicht auf eigentumsrechtliche fragen zu
reduzieren es geht um die historische
frage der forschungsleistung nach
jetzigem stand gehen wir davon aus dass
wenn der anhörung den nachweis führen
können dass wilhelm prinz von preußen
dem nationalsozialismus in erheblichem
maße vorschub geleistet hat meine damen
und herren mir ist es wichtig die
intention des gesetzes von 94 ernst zu
nehmen denn der gesetzgeber hat hier
bewusst fragen zum eigentumsrecht mit
der frage der historischen verantwortung
verbunden
er wollte damit gerechtigkeit all
diejenigen diejenigen gegenüber schaffen
die durch krieg verfolgung vertreibung
und enteignung alles verloren haben
der gesetzgeber wollte gezielt nicht
diejenigen entschädigen die dem
nationalsozialismus zur macht verholfen
haben und der diktatur den weg bereitet
haben diejenigen also durch die wie es
im hugenberg kurzen von 2005
ihren unrechts maßnahmen erst möglich
wurden also die vernichtung der
europäischen juden und andere verbrechen
des nationalsozialismus
es geht um deutsche geschichte eine
geleistete ausgleichsleistung ohne die
frage der vorschub leistung zu klären
käme einem nachträglichen freisprechen
von schuld gleich und darum ist diese
frage der erheblichen vorschub leistung
die alles entscheidende ich danke ihnen
vielen dank
nächster redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
ansgar heveling
[Applaus]
nein das wird natürlich nicht auf
geräten zeit aber die uhr läuft trotzdem
schon weil hier schon nächste redner für
die cdu/csu-fraktion ansgar heveling 40
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen das
staatsministerium wird daher ersucht
erstens über die bisher stattgefundenen
verhandlungen mit den hohen sonnen
bezüglich bzw ihren vertretern dem
landtag bericht zu erstatten
zwei uns jede weitere verhandlungen
sofort einzustellen
drittens dem landtag einen gesetzentwurf
vorzulegen der die entschädigungslose
enteignung des sogenannten
privateigentums der hohenzollern
zugunsten des staates enthält meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen das ist
nicht der antrag der fraktion die linke
auf drucksache 19 14 729 das ist der
antrag von wilhelm pieck kennen wir alle
aus der ddr im preußischen landtag am 11
oktober 1926 das ist das stenografischen
protokoll
er ist in den forderungen dem was die
linke heute fordert zum verwechseln
ähnlich und man mag sich fragen wie viel
weimar steckt denn heute noch in unserer
berliner republik und schauen wir uns
schauen wir uns die historische
entwicklungen doch einmal genauer ein
man muss festhalten dass sich sowohl das
reich als auch das land preußen
letztlich die politik an der aufteilung
des cohen vermögens nach der absetzung
der fürsten vielfach verhoben haben
insbesondere eine politik der damals
linken seite des politischen spektrums
so wie sie sich im oktober 1926 im
preußischen landtag manifestiert hat
meinte mit stimmungsmache gegen die
vormals regierenden häuser rechts setzen
zu können der entsprechende
volksentscheid ist seinerzeit krachend
gescheitert und die damalige extreme
emotionale aufladung des themas dürfte
mit dazu beigetragen haben dass eben bis
heute fragen im zusammenhang mit der
zuordnung von eigentums positionen mit
dem nachfolge ländern preußens dem bund
und den ehemals der ehemals regierenden
familie ungeklärt geblieben sind
den fehler aus der zeit der weimarer
republik aus den jahren 1925 1926
sollten wir jetzt nicht wiederholen
es ist an der zeit eigentumsverhältnisse
rechtsstaatlich zu klären aus dem
republikanischen geist ist eine
bundesrepublik hervorgegangen
in der recht und gesetz allgemein gelten
und jeden bürger auch wenn er einem
ehemaligen herrscherhaus angehört
transparente und rechtsstaatliche
verfahren garantiert sind
er kann rechtspositionen einforderung
über die dann nach recht und gesetz
entschieden wird oder die einer
gütlichen einigung zugeführt werden
es wäre fatal die im bürger- oder den
bürgern namens preußen die
geltendmachung von rechten auf grund
einer politischen einzelfall
entscheidung zu nehmen so wie es die
linke fordert es mag die nähe zu den vor
republikanischen zeiten gewesen sein die
weimar beim thema eigentums zuordnung in
die situation hat schlittern lassen
letztlich mit vor konstitutionellen
gedanken an die aufteilung von staats-
und privateigentum herangegangen so zu
sein
hinzu kommt dass die weiteren
umwälzungen in unserem land die
nationalsozialistische gewaltherrschaft
sowie die enteignung während der
sowjetischen besatzungszeit die sachlage
nicht unbedingt vereinfacht haben zum
einen muss geklärt werden welche güter
welche eigentums positionen im jahr 1926
tatsächlich teil des privateigentums der
hohenzollern geworden sind ja natürlich
ist die auslegung von recht besonders
dann schwierig wenn es brüche in der
staatsform und transformationsprozesse
gegeben hat denn dann verändern sich
kategorien von recht und
selbstverständlich ist der übergang von
der monarchie zur republik
beziehungsweise der wandel vom
feudalismus zur bürgerlichen
gesellschaft ein solcher umbruchs
prozess gewesen
insofern hat sich der gehalt des
eigentums begriffs fundamental gewandelt
werden wir heute eigentum mit
privateigentum verstehen und auch
öffentliches eigentum den rechtsregeln
des privateigentums folgt ist die vor
konstitutionelle zuordnung gerade mit
blick auf frühere herrscher familien
deutlich komplizierter medizinischer
eigentumsverhältnisse kronen eigentum
öffentliches eigentum privateigentum
alles das zu sortieren ist nicht einfach
aber wir sollten es vereinbarung und
eben auch im streitfall den gerichten
überlassen zu entscheiden welche der
ehemaligen eigentumsformen in unsere
heutige eigentumsordnung wie einzuordnen
sind farblos wird die situation auch
durch die gesetzlichen regelungen aus
der zeit der wiedervereinigung
komplizierter denn es ist auch unklar ob
das enteignete privateigentum der
hohenzollern heute überhaupt noch
zurückgefordert werden kann
denn der deutsche bundestag hat 1994 per
gesetz die wird entscheidung getroffen
das enteignetes vermögen nicht
zurückgefordert werden kann wenn dem
nationalsozialistischen systemen
erheblich vorschub geleistet worden ist
was aber unter dieser formulierung und
dann ist es eben ein wirklich
unbestimmter rechtsbegriff erheblichen
vorschub leisten zu verstehen ist das
ist ebenso schwierig rechtlich zu
definieren wie tatsächlich festzustellen
aus der öffentlichen debatte wissen wir
und das ist hier eben auch schon
angesprochen worden
das renommierte historiker für diese
frage durchaus zu entgegengesetzten
ergebnissen kommen um hier über nicht
jahrelang vor gericht zu handeln lohnt
es zunächst einmal zu versuchen auf dem
verhandlungswege zu einer einigung zu
kommen
davon kann unter umständen auch die
allgemeinheit profitieren denn der weg
der linken gue rechtlich gerichtlich
zugesprochenen durch vergesellschaftung
gegebenenfalls wieder zu enteignen ist
jedenfalls kein schlüssiger vorschlag
denn da beißt sich die katze doch in den
schrank schwanz enteignung in der
bundesrepublik sind unter dem
grundgesetz natürlich zu entschädigen
als rheinischer katholik und mit den
beutel preußer stehe ich sicherlich
nicht im verdacht parteigänger der
preußen zu sein es geht mir viel mehr um
den republikanischen geist das
allgemeine gesetz als maßstab des
politischen handelns zu sehen und nicht
die möglicherweise willkürliche
einzelfall entscheidungen aus über
router überhöhter emotionen vielen dank
vielen dank
[Musik]
nächster redner in dieser debatte über
erbansprüche und mögliche entschädigung
an die hohenzollern ist marc jungen von
der fdp-fraktion der kultur und
medienpolitische sprecher frau
präsidentin meine damen und herren wir
lernen aus der heutigen debatte die
methode der antifa politisch missliebige
bürger als nazis anzuschwärzen um sie
ins gesellschaftliche abseits zu stellen
und sie haben wahrnehmen ihrer rechte zu
hindern
diese methode praktizieren die linken
und teils unterstützt auch durch die
grünen hier im deutschen bundestag
genauso kein wunder wo sie ja schon mit
antifa abzeichen auch hier aufgetreten
sind
betroffen von ihrer nazi keule ist heute
das haus hohenzollern also die
nachfahren der preußischen könige und
des letzten deutschen kaisers das dem
nationalsozialistischen system angeblich
in erheblicher weise vorschub geleistet
haben soll wie sie schreiben lesen sie
doch bitte die gutachten der historiker
clark und güter die explizit zum
gegenteiligen schluss kommen über den
kronprinzen wilhelm den sie besonders
auf dem kieker haben schreibt professor
klar
zitat kronprinz william hat im
nationalsozialistischen system keinen
erheblichen vorschub geleistet zitat
ende
er war sicher kein vorbildlicher
demokrat da sind wir uns einig aber er
hat er ist eine der politisch
zurückhaltendsten und am wenigsten
kompromittierten personen des deutschen
kaiser hauses gewesen wie professor
clark schreibt wenn es nach ihrem
geschichts glitzernden antrag geht dann
soll es aber keine verhandlungen der
bundesregierung mit den hohenzollern
über die rückgabe von kulturgütern mehr
geben und nicht genug damit
falls die gerichte eine solche rückgabe
anordnen
dann will die linke diese umgehend vom
staat wieder in
eigenen zehen enteignen und den besitz
anderer leute verteilen das können sie
am besten ihr antrag atmet nicht den
geist der gerechtigkeit wie sie vorgeben
sondern den ungeist des ressentiments
und er ist verfassungswidrig
interessant ist ja schon dass sie jetzt
nicht nur genau dieselbe begründung für
die enteignung voran führen wie damals
schon die sowjetische
militäradministration sondern sich
ausdrücklich dazu zu deren entscheidung
bekennen eine entscheidung eines
unrechtssystems das millionen
menschenleben auf dem gewissen hat meine
damen und herren das ganze vermögen der
ddr und damit ja auch ihr parteivermögen
ist durch in der eigenen zustande
gekommen da muss man auch mal erinnern
durch ein totalitäres kleptokraten
system das für sie aber natürlich kein
unrechtsstaat war
wie wir wissen im kern geht es in diesem
antrag aber um etwas ganz anderes das
haus hohenzollern symbolisiert preußen
und damit einen wichtigen teil der
deutschen geschichte unserer
erinnerungskultur meine damen und herren
braucht ein neues weltbild das frei ist
von unkritischer verherrlichung das aber
auch nicht im ideologischen
geschichtsbild des sowjetkommunismus
folgt wie sie es hier immer noch zu tun
scheinen so lange weite teile der
politik linkslastige historiker und
medien wie auch sogenannte spaß machen
vom schlage eines jahren böhmermann mit
allen mitteln antifaschistische
klischees und ressentiments bedienen ist
ein solches differenziertes preußen bild
in weiter ferne
wir werden uns weiter dafür stark machen
dass es zum teil der deutschen
erinnerungskultur wird und deshalb
lehnen wir lehnt die fdp fraktion ihren
antrag ab vielen dank
sagt marc jungen kündigt das schon
einmal an
über diesen antrag wird nicht sofort
abgestimmt sondern er geht dann erst mal
in die entsprechenden ausschüsse von
daher wird es dann hier auch noch eine
weitere debatte darüber geben nun
spricht aber erstmal martin rabanus von
den sozialdemokraten
nach diesem versuch der romantischen
verklärung der monarchie durch herrn
kollegen jungen unterstelle ich für die
spd zunächst einmal fest damit dass am
anfang der debatte auch klar ist dass
wir freiwilligen entschädigungszahlungen
als fraktion im deutschen bundestag
nicht zustimmen werden erste gewerbe
zweite bewertung dann mit blick auf die
kolleginnen und kollegen der linken
das ist natürlich auch ein besonderer
husarenritt uns jetzt diese stunde mit
dem dürren antrag aus dem letzten
november zu befassen wo wir in zwei
wochen tatsächlich eine experten
anhörung im ausschuss verabredet haben
übrigens ganz maßgeblich auf den wunsch
der fraktion bündnis 90 grüne und von
dem kollegen grunde und weniger auch
getrieben durch die eigene fraktion
jedenfalls eine expertenanhörung machen
und es wird wäre der sache
wahrscheinlich dienlicher gewesen sich
nun erstmal in dieser anhörung mit den
neuen experten schlau zu machen dann in
ruhe das auszuwerten und dann zu schauen
wie man parlamentarisch initiativ wird
also liebe kollegen der linken das wird
nicht einmal diesem thema gerecht wie
sie hier parlamentarisch vorgehen
[Applaus]
aber dass wir uns nicht missverstehen
dass das auch klar ist das was die
familie hohenzollern hier veranstaltet
mit verlaub das ist schon rutschbahn und
für alle diejenigen die den begriff kurz
bündig kennen ist ein etwa vater und
mutter erschlagen und anschließend
waisenrente beantragen
das ist das was eigentlich passiert und
der gipfel ist der gipfel ist dann
tatsächlich das wohnrechte forderungen
wieder nach dem lebenslangen wohnrecht
in schloss cecilienhof das hat
erstaunlicherweise nein ich korrigiere
erfreulicherweise die familie
hohenzollern ja selber gemerkt dass sie
damit über das ziel hinaus geschossen
ist
aber genau diese maßlosigkeit ist ja das
was auch zu der öffentlichen empörung
geführt hat und mal ehrlich man kann das
ja auch verstehen dass man sich darüber
öffentlich empört
ich hätte wahrscheinlich persönlich
nicht die worte gewählt die bernd
stegemann im cicero gewählt hat der vom
familien clan der hohenzollern
gesprochen hat und zitat der über 1000
jahre mit die mitteleuropäische
geschichte mitkriegen vetternwirtschaft
und katastrophen heimgesucht habe und
zitat nach den letzten beiden totalen
niederlagen wieder angelaufen komme um
nun auch die aushändigung seines
kriminellen zusammen gerafften reichtums
zu klagen
ich hätte wie gesagt diese worte so
nicht gewählt aber ganz ehrlich ich habe
es gerne gelesen und man hat so den
gedanken so ganz unrecht hatte herr
stegemann bei seiner bewertung nicht
das ist aber sozusagen so die eine seite
das ist die moralische vielleicht die
emotionale will ich mal sagen die andere
seite die will ich hier aber auch
ansprechen
das ist die dass wir hier eine
rechtsstaatliche haben in einer
demokratie und in einem rechtsstaat und
in dieser demokratie und in diesem
rechtsstaat in dem wir leben ist es
völlig in ordnung wenn auch die familie
hohenzollern
ihr recht für ihr recht kämpft oder für
das kämpft dass sie für ihr recht hält
das ist völlig in ordnung darum geht es
in den gesprächen die übrigens
tatsächlich nicht geheim waren aber
nicht so im fokus der öffentlichkeit
jedenfalls in diesen gesprächen und
darum geht es auch in den anhängigen
prozessen vor gericht und das ist
richtig so und dass das möglich ist und
auch für hohenzollern möglich ist es
werde ich persönlich und das wird die
spd fraktion auch immer verteidigen das
heißt nicht dass wir uns damit zu
interessenvertretern von ehemaligen
hochadel machen nein wir machen uns
damit zu interessenvertretern unserer
demokratie und unseres rechtsstaates für
diese öffentliche klarstellung hat sich
die debatte dann wiederum gelohnt und
tatsächlich machen wie die anhörung in
knapp 14 tagen im kulturausschuss um für
uns als parlamentarier noch einmal die
fakten klar zu kriegen aber auch um die
fakten noch einmal öffentlich breit
zugänglich machen zu können denn die
debatten laufen seit anfang der 90er
jahre dass das hier in der
parlamentsdebatte paar mal erwähnt
worden und wir wollen die öffentliche
wahrnehmung da weiter stärken wir wollen
dass das verfahren transparent
weitergeführt wird zu entscheiden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das habe ich
bereits gesagt haben aus meiner sicht
jetzt gerichte das heißt im
umkehrschluss auch das
vergleichsverhandlungen solange
gerichtsverhandlungen laufen keinen sinn
machen und wenn es letzte entscheidungen
der gerichte gibt werden wir sehen was
überhaupt zum schluss noch übrig bleibt
an handlungsbedarf und abschließend kann
ich nur noch einmal unterstreichen die
spd jedenfalls wird freiwilligen
zahlungen
nicht zustimmen herzlichen dank
[Applaus]